eran llevados totalmente desnudos a la plaza pública
donde tenían que golpear sus nalgas contra una piedra especial
mientras una multitud se burlaba de ellos.
En el siglo XVII en Francia
los dueños de negocios fallidos eran llevados al centro del mercado,
donde el comienzo de su bancarrota era anunciado públicamente.
Y para evitar su encarcelamiento inmediato,
tenían que usar un bonete verde
para que todos supieran que eran fracasados.
Por supuesto, estos son ejemplos extremos.
Pero es importante recordar
que cuando castigamos excesivamente a los que fracasan,
sofocamos la innovación y la creación de negocios,
los motores del crecimiento económico en cualquier país.
Ha pasado el tiempo y hoy no humillamos públicamente a los empresarios fracasados.
Y ellos no transmiten sus fracasos en las redes sociales.
De hecho, creo que todos podemos relacionarnos con el dolor del fracaso.
Pero no compartimos los detalles de esas experiencias.
Y lo entiendo muy bien, yo también he estado allí.
Tenía un negocio que fracasó
y compartir esa historia fue increíblemente difícil.
De hecho, requirió 7 años, una buena dosis de vulnerabilidad
y la compañía de mis amigos.
Esta es la historia de mi fracaso.
Cuando estaba en la universidad, estudiando negocios,
conocí a un grupo de mujeres indígenas.
Vivían en una comunidad rural pobre en el estado de Puebla, en el centro de México.
Hacían hermosos productos hechos a mano.
Y cuando las conocí y vi su trabajo,
decidí que quería ayudar.
Con algunos amigos, cofundé una empresa social
con la misión de ayudar a las mujeres a crear un flujo de ingresos
y mejorar su calidad de vida.
Hicimos todo siguiendo el manual,
tal y como lo aprendimos en la escuela de negocios.
Conseguimos inversores,
pasamos mucho tiempo construyendo el negocio y entrenando a las mujeres.
Pero pronto nos dimos cuenta de que éramos principiantes.
Los productos hechos a mano no se estaban vendiendo,
y el plan financiero que habíamos hecho era totalmente irreal.
De hecho, trabajamos años sin salario,
esperando que sucediera un milagro,
que mágicamente llegara una gran compradora
e hiciera rentable el negocio.
Pero ese milagro nunca sucedió.
Al final, tuvimos que cerrar el negocio
y eso me rompió el corazón.
Empecé todo para producir un impacto positivo
en la vida de las artesanas.
Y sentí que hice lo opuesto.
Me sentí tan culpable
que decidí ocultar este fracaso
de mis conversaciones y mi currículum por años.
No conocía a otros empresarios fallidos,
y pensé que era la única perdedora en el mundo.
Una noche, 7 años después, salí con algunos amigos
y estábamos hablando de la vida del emprendedor.
Y, por supuesto, salió el tema del fracaso.
Decidí confesar a mis amigos la historia de mi negocio fallido.
Y compartieron historias similares.
En ese momento un pensamiento se hizo realmente claro en mi mente:
todos mis amigos eran fracasos.
(Risas)
Siendo más seria, esa noche me di cuenta
de que A: yo no era la única perdedora en el mundo,
y B: todos tenemos fracasos ocultos.
Por favor díganme si eso no es verdad.
Esa noche fue como un exorcismo para mí.
Me di cuenta de que compartir fracasos nos hace más fuertes, no más débiles.
Y estar abierta a mi vulnerabilidad
me ayudó a conectarme con los demás de una manera más profunda y significativa
y aceptar las lecciones de la vida que no había aprendido previamente.
Como consecuencia de esta experiencia
de compartir historias de negocios que no funcionaron,
decidimos crear una plataforma de eventos
para ayudar a otros a compartir sus historias de fracaso.
Y la llamamos Fuckup Nights. [Noches de mierda]
Años más tarde, también creamos un centro de investigación
dedicado a la historia del fracaso
y sus implicaciones en los negocios, las personas y la sociedad
y como nos encantan los nombres geniales, lo llamamos el Instituto de Fracasos.
Ha sido sorprendente ver
que cuando una emprendedora se para en un escenario
y comparte una historia de fracaso,
ella realmente puede disfrutar esa experiencia.
No tiene que ser un momento de vergüenza y humillación,
como solía ser en el pasado.
Es una oportunidad para compartir las lecciones aprendidas
y construir empatía.
También hemos descubierto
que cuando los miembros de un equipo comparten sus fracasos, sucede la magia.
Los lazos se fortalecen y la colaboración se vuelve más fácil.
A través de nuestros eventos y proyectos de investigación,
hemos encontrado algunos hechos interesantes.
Por ejemplo, que los hombres y las mujeres reaccionan de una manera diferente
después del fracaso de un negocio.
La reacción más común entre los hombres
es comenzar un nuevo negocio dentro de un año tras el fracaso,
pero en un sector diferente,
mientras que las mujeres deciden buscar trabajo
y posponer la creación de un nuevo negocio.
Nuestra hipótesis es que esto sucede
porque las mujeres tienden a sufrir más por el síndrome impostor.
Creemos que necesitamos algo más para ser una buena emprendedora.
Pero he visto que en muchos casos, las mujeres tienen todo lo necesario.
Solo tenemos que dar el paso.
Y en el caso de los hombres,
es más común ver que sienten que tienen suficiente conocimiento
y solo necesitan ponerlo en práctica en otro lugar con mejor suerte.
Otro hallazgo interesante ha sido
que existen diferencias regionales sobre cómo los empresarios enfrentan el fracaso.
Por ejemplo, la reacción más común
después del fracaso de un negocio en el continente americano
es volver a la escuela.
Mientras que en Europa, la reacción más común es buscar un terapeuta.
(Risas)
No estamos seguros de cuál es la mejor reacción
después del fracaso de una empresa,
pero esto es algo que estudiaremos en el futuro.
Otro hallazgo interesante ha sido
el profundo impacto que la política pública
tiene en los empresarios fracasados.
Por ejemplo, en mi país, en México,
el entorno regulatorio es tan difícil,
que cerrar un negocio puede llevarte mucho tiempo y mucho dinero.
Comencemos con el dinero.
En el mejor escenario posible,
suponiendo que no tienes problemas con los socios,
proveedores, clientes, empleados,
en el mejor escenario posible,
cerrar oficialmente un negocio te costará USD 2000.
Que es mucho dinero en México.
Alguien que gana el salario mínimo
tendría que trabajar durante 15 meses para ahorrar esta cantidad.
Ahora, hablemos del tiempo.
Como sabrán, en la mayor parte del mundo en desarrollo,
la expectativa de vida promedio de una empresa es de 2 años.
En México, el proceso de cierre oficial de un negocio lleva dos años.
¿Qué sucede cuando la expectativa de vida promedio de una empresa
es tan similar al tiempo que te llevará cerrarlo si no funciona?
Por supuesto, esto desalienta la creación de negocios
y promueve la economía informal.
De hecho, la investigación econométrica ha demostrado
que si el proceso de declaración de quiebra
toma menos tiempo y menos dinero,
más empresas nuevas entrarán al mercado.
Por esta razón, en 2017
propusimos una serie de recomendaciones de política pública
para el procedimiento de cierre oficial de negocios en México.
Por todo un año,
trabajamos con empresarios de todo el país
y con el Congreso.
Y la buena noticia es que logramos ayudar a cambiar la ley.
¡Hurra!
(Aplausos)
La idea es que cuando entre en vigor la nueva regulación,
los empresarios podrán cerrar sus negocios en un procedimiento en línea
eso es más rápido y barato.
(Suspira)
En la noche que inventamos Fuckup Nights,
nunca imaginamos que el movimiento crecería tanto.
Estamos en 80 países ahora.
En ese momento, nuestra única intención
era poner el tema del fracaso sobre la mesa.
Para ayudar a los amigos a ver que
el fracaso es algo de lo que debe hablarse.
No es causa de humillación, como solía ser en el pasado,
o una causa de celebración, como dicen algunas personas.
De hecho, quiero confesarles algo.
Cada vez que escucho tipos o estudiantes de Silicon Valley presumiendo de
fracasar rápido como si eso no fuera gran cosa, siento vergüenza ajena.
Porque creo que hay un lado oscuro en el mantra "fracasa rápido".
Por supuesto, fracasar rápido es una gran manera de acelerar el aprendizaje
y evita perder el tiempo.
Pero me temo que cuando presentamos un fracaso rápido
a los empresarios como su única opción,
podríamos estar promoviendo la pereza.
Podríamos estar promoviendo que los empresarios se rindan muy fácilmente.
También temo que la cultura del fracaso rápido
podría estar minimizando las devastadoras consecuencias
del fracaso de un negocio.
Por ejemplo, cuando mi empresa social murió,
la peor parte fue volver a la comunidad indígena
y decir a las mujeres que el negocio había fracasado
y era mi culpa.
Para algunas personas esto podría verse
como una gran oportunidad de aprendizaje para mí,
pero la verdad es que el cierre de este negocio
representaba mucho más que eso.
Significaba que las mujeres dejarían de recibir un ingreso
que realmente necesitaban.
Por esta razón, quiero proponer algo.
Quiero proponer que así como dejamos de lado la idea
de humillar públicamente a empresarios fracasados,
debemos dejar de lado la idea de que fracasar rápido es siempre lo mejor.
Y quiero proponer un nuevo mantra:
fracasar conscientemente.
Debemos recordar que las empresas se componen de personas,
las empresas no son entidades que aparecen y desaparecen
mágicamente sin consecuencias.
Cuando una empresa muere, algunas personas pierden sus trabajos
y otras su dinero.
Y en el caso de las empresas sociales y verdes,
la muerte de este negocio puede tener un impacto negativo
sobre los ecosistemas o comunidades a los que intentaban servir.
Pero ¿qué significa fracasar conscientemente?
Significa ser consciente del impacto, de las consecuencias
del fracaso de ese negocio.
Ser consciente de las lecciones aprendidas.
Y siendo consciente de la responsabilidad
para compartir esos aprendizajes con el mundo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)